Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going take a
collection of photos like these,
and magically, create a video where
we can fly through these photos.
How is this even possible? Especially that
the input is only a handful of photos.
Well, we give it to a learning algorithm
and ask it to synthesize a photorealistic
video where we fly through the scene
as we please. That sounds impossible.
Especially that some information is given
about the scene, but this is really not much.
And everything in between these photos has
to be synthesized here. Let’s see how well
this new method can perform that,
but don’t expect too much…and….wow.
It took a handful of photos and filled in the
rest so well that we got a smooth and creamy video
out of it. So, the images certainly look good in
isolation. Now let’s compare it to the real world
images that we already have, but have hidden from
the algorithm, and hold on to your papers…wow,
this is breathtaking. It is not a great
deal different, is it? Does this mean…yes!
It means that it guesses what reality
should look like almost perfectly.
Now note that this mainly applies for looking
at these images in isolation. As soon as we
weave them together into a video and start flying
through the scene, we will see some flickering,
artifacts, but that is to be expected. The AI
has to create so much information from so little,
and the tiny inaccuracies that appear in each
image are different, and when played abruptly
after each other, this introduces these artifacts.
So, which regions should we look at to find these
flaws? Well, usually regions where we have
very little information in our set of photos,
and a lot of variation when we move our head.
For instance, visibility around thin structures
is still a challenge. But of course, you know the
joke - how do you spot a Two Minute Papers viewer?
They are always looking behind thin
fences. Shiny surfaces are a challenge
too as they reflect their environment and
change a lot as we move our head around.
So how does it compare to previous methods?
Well, it creates images that are sharper and
more true to the real images. Look! What you see
here is a very rare sight. Usually, when we see
a new technique like this emerge, it almost always
does better on some datasets, and worse on others.
The comparisons are almost always a wash. But
here? Not at all. Not in the slightest. Look,
here you see four previous techniques, four
scenes, and three different ways of measuring
the quality of the output images. And almost
none of it matters, because the new technique
reliably outperforms all of them, everywhere.
Except here, in this one case, depending on how
we measure how good a solution is. And even
then, it’s quite close. Absolutely amazing.
Make sure to also have a look at the paper in
the video description to see that it can also
perform filmic tone mapping, change the
exposure of the output images, and more.
So, how did they pull this off? What hardware
do we need to train such a neural network?
Do we need the server warehouses of
Google or OpenAI to make this happen?
No, not at all! And here comes the best part…if
you have been holding on to your papers so far,
now, squeeze that paper, because all it takes is
a consumer graphics card and 12 to 24 hours of
training. And after that, we can use the neural
network for as long as we wish. So, recreating
reality from a handful of photos with a neural
network that some people today can train at home
themselves? The pace of progress in AI research
is absolutely amazing. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!